la viruela cínica también conocida como
empox es una enfermedad poco frecuente
causada por un germen muy pequeño el
virus de la viruela del mono como la
mayoría de las infecciones víricas la
viruela cívica puede comenzar con
síntomas parecidos a los de la gripe
entre los que se incluyen sensación de
agotamiento escalofríos fiebre dolor de
cabeza dolores musculares ganglios
linfáticos inflamados congestión nasal
dolor de garganta o tos
estos síntomas suelen ir seguidos de una
erupción plana en determinadas zonas del
cuerpo como los genitales la región anal
la cara la boca las manos los pies y el
pecho luego la erupción puede
convertirse en llagas elevadas parecidas
a granos llenas de líquido de pus que
suele ser muy dolorosa
esta erupción suele durar alrededor de
una semana y luego empieza a formar
costras y a desprenderse a medida que
aparece piel nueva
si bien no existe un tratamiento
específico para la viruela cívica la
mayoría de las personas presentan
síntomas leves y mejoran sin que este
sea necesario la enfermedad dura entre 2
y 4 semanas
sin embargo como la erupción suele ser
muy dolorosa es posible que el médico le
aconseje tomar analgésicos para sentirse
mejor
si su sistema inmunitario está
debilitado o si está embarazada y corre
el riesgo de enfermarse gravemente
pueden recetarle un medicamento
antivírico
para prevenir el contagio de la viruela
cívica puede hacer lo siguiente evita el
contacto estrecho con personas que
tengan viruela cívica hasta que la
erupción se haya curado por completo
evite el contacto estrecho con animales
como monos y roedores que puedan estar
infectados
evite tocar zonas y objetos que haya
utilizado una persona con viruela cívica
y lávese las manos de manera frecuente
con jabón o con un desinfectante para
manos a base de alcohol a las personas
con alto riesgo de contraer viruela
cívicas se les puede recomendar una
vacuna que es eficaz tanto contra la
viruela como contra la viruela címica
las personas de alto riesgo son quienes
hayan tenido un contacto estrecho piel
con piel en las últimas dos semanas con
alguien que tenga o pueda tener viruela
címica Especialmente con hombres que
mantienen relaciones sexuales con
hombres en una zona geográfica en la que
se esté propagando la enfermedad y
cualquier persona cuyo trabajo puede
exponerla a los ortopoxvirus como los
trabajadores de laboratorio y sanitarios
las vacunas contienen un ortopoxvirus
debilitado llamado baccinia que no puede
multiplicarse Ni causar enfermedad
Dado que los ortopoxvirus son tan
similares las vacunas pueden ayudar a
proteger tanto contra el virus variola
que causa la viruela como contra el
virus de la viruela cívica
si nació antes de 1972 y se vacunó
contra la viruela en esa época o antes
es posible que tenga cierta protección
contra la enfermedad grave pero no está
protegido contra la infección ni contra
el contagio
para más información sobre el
tratamiento y la prevención de la
viruela cívica consulte a su médico